PETER LEWIS: All right, hello.
Hello, everybody, welcome.
My name is Peter, and I am the
product manager for Eddystone
and the Google beacon platform,
and I am uncomfortably
excited today to be talking
to you about location
and proximity superpowers.
So, we're going to cover
a whole bunch of stuff,
and it's going to be awesome.
So, if my clicker works-- oh,
that was the laser pointer.
We're going to get in some
code, but before we do that,
I want to introduce
you to my dog.
This is Oscar.
Oscar is like my
sidekick, I suppose,
if we're talking
about superpowers.
He is a four-year-old Papillon,
and one of my favorite things
is taking him up to
Hampstead Heath in London,
near where I live, and
taking him for a long walk
amongst all the
trees and the bushes.
And while I'm walking along,
he's constantly sniffing,
discovering all the
interesting smells, like,
is this an important bush?
Is this is a stick I
should be playing with?
He has a fantastic sense of
all of the important places
and objects that are around
him, and this session
is about to make your
users' devices almost as
awesome as Oscar.
So, today I want to
talk to you a bit
about a few location-based
experiences.
So, here are a few examples
from within Google Apps.
In the Photos app, I
can search for photos
I took when I was at
Google in New York.
There's timeline for helping
users to rediscover places
that they've been to, and the
experiences they've had there.
And there's sort of
popular times for one
of my favorite restaurants
here in London, that reminds me
it's been two months.
I should probably go again.
And these kind of
location-based experiences
make apps really compelling.
If you can provide
services to your users that
take account of the important
places and objects to them,
then you can build engagements
and be much more successful.
So, all of these are powered by
a complicated array of sensors
in the user's device, but the
experience at the end of it
is really simple.
They use Wi-Fi,
cell tower location,
GPS to produce
this kind of thing.
But what we want to do is to
provide really simple APIs
to be able to develop your
own apps, and even in cases
where you don't have an app,
on top of this platform.
So, today we will
cover Eddystone.
Eddystone is the open
beacon format from Google,
and we want to make it
so that the beacons you
have on your desk actually
become useful quite quickly.
We're then going
to talk about how
to link your beacons
with the Cloud,
so that you can think of them
much more like Cloud objects.
That is, we're going to
talk about attachments,
subscriptions, and nearby--
and sharing those beacons
with others, so that
this physical widget gets
all of the power of the Cloud.
And then last up, we're
going to talk about something
new that was announced an hour
ago in stage one, I think.
Powering experiences at
your venue through Google.
So, even in the case where you
don't have your app installed,
how can you use beacons to
bring awesome experiences
to your users?
So, what is the technology
we're going to use?
Well, we're going
to use beacons.
And, in fact, beacons
are not new at all.
If I can advance the slide--
yes, beacons are not new.
So, here's an example of
a beacon, a lighthouse,
and all of the components of
the Google beacon platform
are similar to a lighthouse
and a ship at sea.
So, you have the
lighthouse itself.
That's the Eddystone beacon.
It just sits there and it
broadcasts an identifier
to the world.
Meanwhile, out at sea,
the captain of the ship
has got the telescope.
They're looking out for
all of the beacons that
are around the
coastlines of countries.
That's like the
Nearby API in Android
and the CocoaPod for iOS.
But just sighting the
beacon is not that useful.
You're also going
to need a chart
with all of the beacons
mapped out on it to look up
exactly where you are,
and that chart is provided
by the Proximity Beacon
API, which is the Cloud
service that you can use to
register beacons with Google.
So, we're going to go
through each of those parts,
but with the Google
beacon platform rather
than lighthouses and ships.
And by the end of
the session you're
going to be able to build
awesome beacon powered
experiences in your
app, and also we're
going to give you some ideas for
how to use beacons in the cases
where your app is not
yet on the user's device.
So, what is a BLE beacon?
Well, I have one just here.
They're sort of
simple, typically
battery-powered
devices that you can
use to mark important places
and objects in the world.
You stick them on the
object and they just
broadcast an identifier.
They do exactly one thing.
The identifier
that they broadcast
is only 31 bytes
long, and by the time
you've gotten rid of all the
headers there's not really very
much space left for content.
So, by placing an abstract
identifier in your beacon
that you mark, you make
devices that come near it
aware of that place.
Because beacons only accept
connections from devices
when they're being
configured, they're
really good for deploying
in public places.
So, you don't want
users' devices
to have to connect to these
Bluetooth things all the time.
You just want your
user's device to have
a great idea about the important
places and objects around it.
So, beacons have been
around for a little while,
and Bluetooth
beacons have as well.
And in the olden days we
sort of had this model,
that you would
deploy a beacon, it
would talk to a
particular app, and it
would probably power a
particular feature in that app.
We're taking a slightly
different approach
with Eddystone and the
Google beacon platform.
We're interested in having
one beacon or many beacons
with many uses.
So, you deploy your
infrastructure once,
and then you can reuse
it multiple times
in different apps
from different people,
all coming to your venue.
So, what is step one?
Well, we've provided an
app for you to get started.
It's called Beacon Tools,
available on the Play
Store and the iOS app store.
Download this app and you'll
be able to talk to beacons.
It's an app that allows
you to register beacons
with the Google Cloud platform.
So, it sits between the beacon
and Proximity Beacon API.
You can register beacons
that have a number
of different frame types.
This is the complete
Eddystone specification.
There are four frame
types in Eddystone.
There's Eddystone UID,
which is the abstract marker
for a particular place.
For cases where you're
interested in controlling
who has access to your beacon
signal, there's Eddystone EID,
and I'll talk a bit
about that in a minute.
Then the third frame type
is a telemetry frame.
This reports on the
beacon's battery level,
which makes it easy to
monitor a fleet of beacons
once they're
deployed in the wild.
And then finally, you
can put a pretty tiny URL
into the beacon frame
itself, and Eddystone URL
forms the backbone
of the physical web.
So, I want to talk a bit
more about Eddystone EID,
and you can see I've made
a beacon with a pretty
colorful center just here.
What that represents is
that the beacon frame itself
is continuously changing.
So, I have a beacon, it's
broadcasting one frame,
and then a few
minutes later it's
broadcasting a different frame.
And your beacon
generates those frames
based upon a cryptographic
key that's stored
within the beacon itself.
That key is also shared
with another service, which
is able to resolve a sighting
of that particular beacon
to a stable ID so that you can
make use of it in your app.
It's particularly
good for cases where
you want to control who has
access to the beacon signal
that you're deploying,
and the good news
is that all of our APIs supports
UID and EID transparently.
So, you don't have to
bother thinking about EID.
You can deploy mixed networks
of UID and EID beacons,
and still talk to them both
through the same Nearby API
and Android.
So, that's Eddystone.
We've got static identifiers
which are, in a sense,
the simplest way to
get started, and we've
got ephemeral
identifiers, and these
are the ones that are ideal for
controlling your beacon signal.
But that's just
the beacon itself.
The real power comes
from the Cloud service
that you associate, where
you put that beacon,
and that is fronted by
Proximity Beacon API.
Proximity Beacon API is an API
that fronts Google's beacon
registry that allows
you to register beacons,
associate information with
them, and add attachments which
can be used by your own app.
So, a beacon object
looks a bit like this.
I've represented it as a
box, and within the box
we've got three attachments
represented by these three
colors.
So, let's have a look at the
beacon registry entry itself.
Here is the list of
properties that you
can associate with a beacon.
First up, you can assign
the beacon a description.
The description of the beacon
is your human readable name
for that particular
beacon, and we'll
talk a bit about how you can
search for things like that
later.
You can add properties
to a beacon,
so it's sometimes useful to
remember the transmit power
that you associate it
with a particular beacon
or some other
properties that are
relevant to your
particular venue.
Then, the next set of objects is
to do with place and location.
When you register a
beacon with Google,
you can associate
a place ID with it
which goes into the heart
of Google's location
infrastructure.
So, all of the out of
place functionality
that I showed earlier
just gets better
when you have a beacon signal
registered with a place ID.
As well as that, beacons enable
new kinds of precise locations.
So, in particular, you can
associate an indoor level
with a beacon, which makes
it much easier for your app
to detect which level a
user is on in a building.
This last field,
expected stability,
allows you to distinguish
between beacons that you deploy
in a static place,
sort of marking
important places in a
building, and those, perhaps,
that are on a bus, or a
food truck, or move around.
Finally, we have the ephemeral
ID registration object,
which keeps all of the records
necessary to support Eddystone
EID.
So, if you're using
Eddystone EID beacons,
you'll need to talk to
this part of the API.
And finally, when you provision
a beacon using the Eddystone
gap service, there
is a key that you
can use to unlock that
particular hardware,
and we can store that
for you to make beacon
administration easier later on.
So, what's next?
We have a beacon, we
have a Cloud service.
On a user's device in the
middle we have the Nearby API.
And I want to take you
on a sort of brief tour
of the Nearby API,
showing how you
can use it to fetch attachments
back to your beacon,
back to your user's device.
So, this is what you need
to put in your manifest.
It's important that
you put your API key
to talk to the
Nearby Messages API.
You also need a service running
in the background for if you
want background beacon
scanning, and you can also
put intent filters in
your manifest as well.
And that's something you
should do because of a reason
I'm going to tell
you about in a bit.
Once you've connected
to Google Play services
in your Android
activity, then this
is the meat of
your subscription.
So, this is where you
tell the nearby API
that, I'm interested
in attachments
of a particular name space
and a particular type.
It's that line under set filter.
So, what happens next?
Well, the Nearby API takes
all of the information
that you've given it and it
does beacon scanning for you.
Notice that you don't have
to care about the actual
bytes that the beacon
is broadcasting.
You've created a subscription
to a Cloud object,
and Nearby is going to hide
all of the sophistication
in the background.
So, Nearby goes out
looking for beacons.
and when it does beacon
scans it shared them
across all apps that have
active subscriptions.
As well as that, when the
Android platform does scans
they're also shared to Nearby.
So, you get a lot more scans
for a lot less battery use.
When Nearby comes out
and finds a beacon, it
will query the Proximity
Beacon API to say, hey,
I found this beacon.
I don't know what it means.
And Proximity Beacon
API will return
attachments that were the ones
that you had subscribed to.
So, let's take a look at what
an attachment looks like.
They're pretty simple objects.
They have these two
important fields.
The first one is the name
space type for the project.
The name space is
owned by your project,
so you have a name space for
your particular developer
console project.
After that you can put a
type for each attachment.
That could be
platforms at a station,
or it could be different
types of vehicle.
It can be anything you want.
And then the second
field is the data
that you associate
with that beacon
under that name space type.
So, this is where you put the
information that you actually
want to get back in your
app when your user sights
that particular beacon.
If you're calling
the API directly,
remember to base 64
encode it, but our tools
take care of that for you.
So, Nearby had this subscription
to a particular name
space and type.
Proximity Beacon
API decided if there
were any attachments
on the beacon that
had been seen that correlated
with your particular
subscription, and
then those attachments
are returned to
your app so that it
can behave as you would expect.
Launched this
morning, if you don't
care about integrating
with APIs and so on,
you can use the
beacon dashboard.
This is a web dashboard that
actually uses the JavaScript
client library to
Proximity Beacon API,
and allows you to visualize
all of your beacons
and edit the information
associated with them.
So, for a particular beacon
object, registering a beacon
just becomes filling in a
bunch of fields on here.
We think this is really cool.
You can also add attachments.
Here's an example
of an attachment
that I added this
morning, and you
can see it's a simple matter of
filling in two fields on a web
dashboard.
You now have a registered
beacon and an attachment
associated with it.
So, where have we come?
Well, we started with a beacon.
We provisioned it
using beacon tools,
which you can get from the Play
Store all the iOS app store.
Then, we associated
that beacon in the Cloud
with Proximity Beacon
API, which allowed
us to create this beacon object
and add attachments to it.
If you didn't want to call the
API, we have the dashboard.
And then down in
the bottom right,
we've got the model of
what happens when a user's
device comes across a beacon.
And as I said earlier, it
doesn't matter whether you're
using Eddystone UID
or Eddystone EID,
Nearby will behave
exactly the same.
You just create a subscription
to the name space and type
of attachment that
you're interested in.
So, I mentioned
earlier that there
are good reasons for registering
beacons in the Cloud,
and one of those is that you
can create a beacon network
and share it with many
different developers.
So, launched recently,
Proximity Beacon API
is one of the first APIs to
use Google Cloud's identity
and access management
roles, giving fine
grained control over
which developers can make
use of your beacon network.
So, here we go.
Here is a picture of the
Google Cloud Platform developer
console, and their Identity
and Access Management,
you can add members
to your project.
So, these are adding
developers who
can do things with resources
that are in your project.
Things like compute engine
instances or data store,
and so on.
And Proximity Beacon
API is one of these,
so once you've enabled the
API you can add a developer
and choose from the roles
that we have available.
So, these are the
new roles, and I
want to just go
through them a bit
and tell you about what
they allow developers
to do with your beacon network.
So, first up is BeaconEditor.
If you grant a
developer this role,
then they're able to add
beacons to your project.
It's important if, for
example, the person who's
writing the app is not the
person who's going and sticking
up the beacon.
The person who's going and
sticking up the beacon,
you want them to be
able to register beacons
to your project
but you don't want
them to be able to fire up
compute engine instances.
So, BeaconEditor is a role
that you can assign to a user
or to a group to enable them
to add beacons to your project.
And it's important to note
that beacon IDs are universally
unique in Google's
beacon registry.
So, once a beacon
has been registered
it can't be registered
by a different project.
Next up we have
AttachmentEditor.
Now, I mentioned
earlier that attachments
have a name spaces
associated with them
and the name space
belongs to your project.
AttachmentEditor
allows you to say,
I want this developer to
be able to add attachments
to my beacons in my name space.
So, that means that
they can add attachments
that can interact with
your app, and they
can do this in combination
with BeaconEditor.
So, they can register a
beacon to your project
and they can add
attachments to it as well
without all of the
other permissions that
come as a result of being
an owner of a project.
Finally, is AttachmentPublisher.
What this allows, you
can say, that developer
can create attachments in their
own name space on my beacons.
So, I have a beacon
network, and I can say,
my friend, here,
I want them to be
able to add attachments
in their own name space
that will talk to their
own app on my beacons.
And these roles and
these new sharing
paradigms allow a
bunch of useful things.
So, here we have three
different phones,
belonging to three
different users,
with three different active
nearby subscriptions,
all talking to the same beacon.
And these attachments can be
added by different developers.
So, there's a lot of
flexibility in the way
that you can use
a beacon network.
You don't any longer just
deploy one beacon for one app.
We have one beacon
with many uses.
Great, yeah, it's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
Right, so, interacting
with Google products.
Sometimes people
come to me and they
say, Peter, PM for beacons.
This is fantastic, but my
app has to be everywhere
in order for it to be useful.
This is not true.
So, what I want
to talk about now
is how you can take your
beacons and interact
with Google products at
the heart of Android,
like Nearby Notifications.
So, Nearby Notifications was
announced just an hour ago
and is available in the
next version of Google Play
services, But what I
want to tell you today
is how you can register
beacons today and add
attachments that will interact
with Nearby Notifications.
Nearby Notifications
allows you to prompt
notifications in Android in
three different categories
of cases.
You can associate web
URLs with your beacons.
So, you've registered a beacon.
You can associate a URL with it.
You can associate app intents.
So, remember earlier
I said, make sure
that you've put intents
in your Android manifest.
You can point to those intents
with a beacon attachment,
and if the user doesn't
have your app installed,
you can have a URL
that's the fallback.
So, if I have your
app installed,
I come near the beacon,
it intents into your app.
If I don't have your
app installed it says,
here is a website.
And then last up, there's
a direct app installs.
So, this is an early
program, and we're
holding it behind the
white list at the moment.
So, if you would like to apply
to have your app white listed
for direct app installs
associated with beacons,
then you can go to
developers.googl
e.com/nearby/notifications and
it will tell you how to get
started.
So, let's have a look at
what these things look like.
Here are three examples
of Nearby Notifications.
Right up at the top we've
got an app for a coffee shop,
and this passed our white list
because of a particular reason,
and that was that
a user could take
an action if they had the app
installed right at that place.
So, it's very much about, is a
user going to install your app
and then do something
immediately with it?
That's a really good candidate
for Nearby Notifications.
In the second case,
this is an example
where, at Kim's
Vitamins, a web URL
was associated with
the beacon that
pointed to a particular website
managed by that business.
And then at the bottom we've
got everybody's favorite example
in San Francisco, apparently,
paying for parking.
Finding an app where
you can pay for parking
and actually use it right
then to pay for the place
where you've just parked
is another good candidate
for Nearby Notifications.
So, let's go back to the beacon
object and have a look at it.
We have three attachments
on this beacon.
The bottom two are
attachments that you added.
So, they're things that
interact with your app.
Maybe you've got some kind of
beacon functionality baked in.
But we want to focus on
the top one, just here,
and what you'll
notice about it is
that the name space for
this particular attachment
is not your project.
This is com.Google.nearby,
a name space
that is reserved for
Nearby Notifications.
Any developer can write
attachments in this name space,
but they can only
attach those attachments
to their own beacons.
So, if you register
a beacon with Google,
you can write into
this name space.
If this other person registers
a beacon with Google,
I cannot write into that
name space on that beacon.
So, you have to own a
beacon in order to take part
with Nearby Notifications.
So, let's have a look.
We have the Nearby
attachment, and you
can see that it's in this
com.Google.nearby name space.
In the type field
we've put en-debug.
So, en is a language code.
We only want to show
your Nearby Notifications
to users who have
set the default
language on their device
to the notification
that you want to show.
And then in the data we've got
some Nearby attachment data.
This is exactly the
same pattern that you
would build if you were putting
functionality in your own app.
So, what does this
data look like?
Well, it's just some JSON
with a title, a description,
and a URL.
you can create this
dead easy, and the URL
is the part that's interesting.
So, there's a little
bit of subtlety here.
I'm going to go through
it quite carefully.
So, here are the three
different categories
of Nearby Notification
that I mentioned before.
Up at the top, this is the
URL that we would associate
with a direct app install.
You can see that it points
to a particular package
in the Android Play store.
In the middle, this
is a URL that we
would associate with if the
user has the app installed,
intent into it.
If they don't have
the app installed,
then we'll fall
back to a website.
And then at the bottom you've
got the simple case, just
a web URL.
The gotcha with
that one is that you
have to remember it's HTTPS,
so HTTP URLS are filtered out.
Right, that is the end of
the content for this talk.
I'm now going to do a demo
for your entertainment
and amusement, that is possibly
the most dangerous demo that's
ever been done.
I'm going to use two
different kinds of radio.
I'm going to use an
unreleased product.
I'm going to use a product that
we launched this afternoon,
and I'm going to use
two different devices.
So, before your very
eyes, here is my beacon.
It's broadcasting,
and in Beacon Tools
I can search for
it just like this.
Excellent, it's shown up.
So, I provisioned this beacon
earlier, and there it is.
I'm going to register it.
I'm glad that nobody
got there before me.
If somebody else had
registered that beacon,
this would not have worked.
Right, what I just did
was, I took this beacon
that was broadcasting
at Eddystone UID
and I registered
it with my project.
You can see that I tested this
maybe seven times before I
got in here.
And this is the beacon
dashboard that I
was talking about earlier.
So, if I refresh it,
fingers crossed, here
is my new beacon that I
just registered right now.
By the way, if this all
works I want you guys
to give a cheer that
is loud enough to wake
the engineers in
London who made it.
So, I can associate some
information with my beacon.
So, the I/O beacon.
This is the human
readable label that I
want to associate with the
beacon so I can find it later.
I can associate a place with it.
So, I can put it in
Amphitheater Parkway,
and this will plug into the
rest of Google's location
infrastructure, as
I mentioned before.
And this particular
beacon, this is not
going to move around, so
I'm going to make it stable.
Now, here are some sort of
useful administrative labels
for me.
So, I can in things
like the TX power,
the transmit power of
this particular beacon.
So, maybe it's broadcasting
at minus 20 DBM.
Great, so, I've now registered
at this beacon with Google,
I've added a description so
that I can find it again,
and I've put a place
ID with it as well.
Next up, I can add
attachments to it.
So, here is the
name space that's
associated with my project,
and it is very easy
to add an attachment.
There we go, I just
press plus, and I now
have a beacon registered
with an attachment to it.
So, I can use Nearby messages
to get that attachment back
in my app.
Tomorrow, probably, you should
go to the code lab's tent,
and there is a code
lab specifically
on Nearby subscriptions
from Nearby messages.
So, make sure you
go there in order
to get some of these
attachments back,
and we've created a zoo
of attachments around I/O,
so if you do it
on your own phone
you'll be able to collect
all of those animals.
Finally is this category,
Nearby Notifications.
So, I said earlier
that you have this JSON
object that you can construct,
but what we decided was that we
could make it easier than that.
So, we just have a web
form that you can fill in.
I can put a title in here,
I can put a description
for the notification
that I want to show.
Can somebody give
me a random word?
AUDIENCE: Bacon!
PETER LEWIS: Bacon,
perfect-- the bacon.
This is going to prove
that I'm doing this live.
I'm going to put it in
English, and how about we just
point to www.google.com.
Great, so I can check
all of the details
I put, and I can create
the attachment like that.
So, what this has done is
created a Nearby Notifications
attachment on that beacon that
I registered on the stage,
live in front of all of you.
Let's go back to the
device over here.
And on this particular phone,
I have Nearby Notifications
running.
So, when I screen on and I pull
down the notification shade,
and I screen on again,
I'm going to see
a couple of websites that
are not the ones that I
was thinking of.
Third time lucky, boo, it
looks like it might not work.
So, what's happening
is it actually
does a beacon scan when
the screen comes on,
and I'm hoping that it
can see this beacon that
is sitting right next to it.
There we go, the bacon.
[APPLAUSE]
I select that, and
google.com appears.
So, we registered the beacon,
we added a Nearby Notifications
attachment to it, and that
took us straight to that link
when the user's device came.
So, that is the Google
beacon platform.
One beacon, many uses.
[MUSIC PLAYING]